blue Lakehead podcast special guests in
here my guy Q my guy Ramses AKA Civic
Cipher what up though for people who
don't know what Civic Cipher is
Rancis I'll let you educate the people
Civic Cipher is you should uh put the
mic in front of YouTube Ramses it is a
radio show
that uh exists to
um
give
the hip-hop Community a little bit more
insight into the goings-on politically
in this country and to give a voice to
the activist element
um uh that moves to create a better
day-to-day life for black and brown
marginalized impoverished communities
Etc what was the inspiration for
starting the show
uh really it was 2020 you know folks
getting out on the street
um and protesting you know let us know
that there was a gap in there was a
gaping hole in the previous space
yes I remember that
anyway tell me more about the gaping
hole no no I'm not going to tell you
about that you should talk about that
I'm here anyway there was a gaping hole
in the media space sure sure and uh in
the media space
um you know uh we are both DJs and
broadcasters
um I'm talking to you like you don't
notice but you got to tell everybody
else for people who don't know Rams this
is like my best friend in the entire
world best man in my wedding yes you
know I've known Kevin since he was
three years old yes so the reason
bootleg Kev is all into hip-hop this is
true it's all him it's all his fault
it's literally his fault it's his fault
you have to play guys when we were
little you know little toys not play
with guys that was what you call it you
called it guys guys yeah like action
figures action figures yes so so
lifelong friend uh best friend but but
yeah um in that in the media space there
wasn't anyone talking about what was
going on the streets no one giving a
voice to the movement no one talking
about you know what explaining the
concepts defund the police how do we you
know create programs to kind of mitigate
you know economic you know instability
and and
you know bring just an activist element
to the to the airwaves we was just if
you would have turned on the radio at
the time it was just rapping and dancing
and singing and fashion and or it was
just very like uh you know obviously in
radio there's not a lot of
uh time or space to really
dive into those conversations right
outside of surface level things right
and so that's exactly what we pushed
back against because
um you know it's it's one thing cute
says it a lot better but I'll try to get
you started there's one thing to
you know profit from Black Culture
because you know a lot of folks at the
top they didn't really look like the
community that who's coaching mostly
nobody at the top there you go mostly
mostly exactly so a lot of them people
were benefiting from it but they didn't
really have a vested interest in
whatever outcomes took place on the
street and we fought against that uh
that
imbalance and so you know yes we we take
a moment we turn the songs off we turn
the music off we have conversations we
educate not just black and brown people
but everybody who lives yeah right
anybody listens to hip-hop we figured
they can be an ally to black and brown
communities they need to understand the
conversations the struggles the
challenges and then by having those
conversations long form in spaces where
people are because it's hard for folks
to seek Out programs like ours if you're
we don't seek out
you know Vietnamese programming no
disrespect but I don't feel like it's
creative for me so I don't expect you
know non-black people to seek out what
would be considered black programming if
they don't feel like it's for them right
so by putting it in the media space
where hip-hop music is can consumed
Black Culture is consumed it feels and
our opinion feels a little bit more
accessible for our listeners and so this
is how we've been able to
um connect with you know radio stations
around the country listeners around the
country it's also available in podcast
form right sure absolutely absolutely so
you know we've been doing that we've
been doing uh and then since then of
course the black Information Network uh
which is a subsidiary of I heart media
has reached out and they've kind of
tapped on us to kind of expand the show
um and then I I do a podcast for them as
well so it's been it's been a wild ride
but you know we're making some progress
Q how do you feel like it's like uh in
terms of just like fiddling in the space
that is missing that there really wasn't
anything sort of that
catered to to the issues or
you know I think your guys's Mission
before and I I don't know why you know
obviously there's I'm sure in certain
markets there's like one-offs of people
who do like shows like this but aren't
necessarily trying to take the national
approach to it so the interesting thing
Kev is that our initial push wasn't for
us to do a show right so it's hard to
tell the story and leave that part out
we didn't we wasn't trying to jump you
know in front of the mic or in front of
the camera perhaps just make sure you
might turn down a little there you go to
tell the story yeah we just thought
somebody should right right when we
first had that first meeting with the PD
it was like hey
you know we got some unrated space
overnight that's running uh are you
talking about at the beat
knrj in Arizona yes sir now the bounce
that's now the bounce that's we're the
reason they changed their name because
well they were crazy Ram just also owns
the beat trademark yeah so there's that
what yeah Ram just owns the beat so they
had to change the whole situation but
and we can talk about that too but
we were in the streets Kevin you know
this more than more than a lot of people
when everything was happening in 2020 a
lot of people were outside with their
kids with their families like listen
there's some things that go that are
going on that have been going on for so
long and we just kind of collectively
all over it yeah for sure but the way
that it was covered on television even
on some broadcast media was just not
that you know called people rioters and
protesters I mean not protesters but
rioters and looters instead of
protesters so Rams is his idea was
listen
there's some people out there whose
voice only goes as far as a bullhorn
right it would be cool if we can just
have them come on the radio right and
have a place where they can say their
piece and tell their story right and we
got some unrated time overnight that's
running what don't drink and drive ads
or something right where we could you
know talk about that right and the
station was initially like yeah that'd
be a great idea yeah we should put
something together and then a month went
by and then a couple months went by and
then a few months went by and just in
the spirit I think in the spirit of
follow-up Ram just went and had a
meeting with you know I'll let you say
the gentleman's name RPD at the time
um
hey remember that thing we talked about
that everybody said would be a good idea
all right are we going to do is do that
yeah and there's so many things they
could have said back to us Kev that we
would have just had to take on the chin
and run with like hey you guys great
idea but we're going to want to do
anything divisive
hey guys wonderful concept you guys
talked about but we don't really do
political in this space have they said
something like that we just thought it
was BS but if we could have took that on
the channel what they said or what he
said more specifically was we don't want
to do a black show
wow and the reason why that part of the
story is important because Civic Cipher
now seems like hey those guys had a
great plan and they ran the play and it
worked that's not what happened right we
pitched an idea to the station
they told us initially okay and this is
a at the time
I mean still is a hip-hop station yes
but it's a hip-hop station it's a
hip-hop station that plays nothing but
nothing but black music that was that
was my charge in Phoenix yes my charge
was that you know a station in place
um 70 black artist and 100 black music
should also align itself be an ally to a
community in need where we're hurting
you know people are dying we're coming
together we're trying to change so that
we can create a better path forward for
our children right my father what's Fred
Rico doing now so in real estate like
every other bum ass PD out there they
can't get a job hey man look I I haven't
kept up I will say this because it's
important to say it I'll talk to Fred
he wished me well on my journey and I
will leave it there but I don't know I
do want to say this too let me let me
say this because you know for folks that
aren't familiar with Civic Cipher
um you know was talking about you know
Kev listening to my city books
um after Fred and I had our meeting I
don't think I don't even think you know
this
um you have to bear in mind I've been a
radio broadcaster my whole Adult Career
up to that point and when I decided to
resign after that meeting
um I had to come to terms with the fact
that I might never broadcast again and
that's a lot to come in terms with
because in Phoenix you know I was kind
of you know at that time especially so
for people who don't know you you
decided to resign after they said we're
not going to put the show on you said
Ramses I don't want to the way that they
said it I don't want to do it it had to
do it the way they said it right so I
wrote my resignation letter but I
addressed it to the City of Phoenix
right
um because the Phoenix had given me my
ratings Phoenix had kept me on the air
across multiple stations and so forth
but I did make one phone call before I
posted that
I called you and you were in Mexico at
the time with your wife and I read that
I remember I was crying yeah I was in
because you imagine when I got to your
house you were still crying yeah the
emotion that goes into that and I didn't
know what was coming next but I read
that letter to you and you was like
there's there's no way you can write
that and not post it post it yeah posted
it and then got shared went viral
um the trades picked it up you know
everyone picked it up and then PD
started reaching out around the country
saying hey we'd like to carry that show
and then of course the podcast
partnership with I heart helped blow it
up even more and you know then the other
shows that I that I ended up doing it
just led to sort of this Snowball Effect
so we had to create that on the spot
when these people started reaching out
we had no name there was no show the
show didn't exist we just had an idea
but you know around this initial
initially resigned both of us from the
beat like okay we don't work here no
more right and then called me and told
me and of course right but just it was
he was that compelled he felt that
strong in that moment like imagine
looking at for the cameras imagine
looking at him
we're not going to do a black show on
the hip-hop station like that's a crazy
it's a crazy thing to say out loud yeah
to me especially you know what I'm
saying so that decision kind of made
itself Kev and
then it was time to get to work yeah Q I
need you to commit to doing this with me
I don't know what it's going to become
because you know it's worked out now we
might top of the year we might be on
almost 70 stations yeah so it's worked
out now so it seemed like we had a plan
and we ran to play like nah it was just
the station made a decision for us we
don't want to do a black show made the
choice for us what happened after that
it just kind of came together so if you
believe in God or the universal you know
whatever your belief system is that's
kind of where those thanks go because we
had no idea and our minds we're never
going to work in radio again because
ramses's letter burned the station down
he named names it was very it was very
very specific but had to be done in that
way yeah you know but but we figured
okay once this is published
I don't know how we're gonna do you know
as far as the career thing after this
yeah so once uh you you the letter goes
viral did they ever like uh they never
even replied to it or try to I had a
brief line of communication to uh the
general manager of the station because
you know we're at a point what's his
name again
um Paul Holton okay what's the other
guy's name that's always there the the
the other old dude that's been there
forever uh Michael Michael malice oh
yeah he was going by okay okay so
Michael wasn't involved but anyway uh
yeah I had a brief line of communication
because we're going back and forth in
the newspaper and then the trades you
know and they're saying it's this I'm
saying it's that you know what I mean
and of course they have to spend they
have a whole business to protect so they
don't mind reframing the conversation
The Narrative around they've been trying
to get somebody else to do the show yeah
yeah I think they hired Cedric ceballo
shout out to said that's my guy yeah but
they hired um him to do it and then I
think it was like Jackie Morales is
another name out in Arizona
um some folks to try to pick up the
slack because the community had since
charged that station with hey you should
be doing what this guy resigned about
you know what I mean so um you know
everybody ended up winning uh again I
kept a brief line of communication open
with Paul I still believe Paul to be you
know friendly with me but obviously
because of where he works in the
situation circumstance he probably can't
talk to me and I honestly I believe that
a lot of those people really had good
intentions it was just one person who
made the wrong decision at the wrong
time and said it the wrong way to the
wrong person yes I've been I was the
president of the black student union in
college NAACP and BSU this isn't new to
me I've been on this this path for my
life trying to make sure everything is
fair and equal because you know we
reached me and you Kev we reach Heights
from playing with toys as a little kid
you know I'm saying we reached high
school they never thought
um and you know for me obviously it
comes with an additional charge for you
two you've been real real about that but
it comes with a charge of okay now we
have to make sure that people that don't
make it to this height
um
we we're doing right by them we're
making the world a little bit better
place a little bit more accessible
um and you know helping change the
narrative so that you know we leave a
legacy that's not just we make some
bread hey what up y'all bootleg Kev
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our newest sponsor man shout out
to the homies at hardean Las Vegas
that's right the number one dispensary
in the whole state of Nevada let alone
in the whole [ __ ] country so many
choices of Premium cannabis ladies and
gentlemen it is like how can I put this
you walk into it you go to Jardin in Las
Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sense
you'll be like yo bootleg Capt sent me
they're gonna take care of you at
hardean when I say selection I mean
selection of the best premium cannabis
in the world the best dispensary there's
a reason why hardeen is world famous
follow them right now Harding underscore
Las Vegas go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview
so how did you end up so you ended up
buying the name the beat trademarking it
yeah yeah in what in what capacity no
one because there's I mean a lot of
radio stations so so there's like major
companies that own the beach sure so
there's there's uh it's funny because
I'm learning all this stuff on the fly
in fact I got a funny story to tell you
about uh trademarks but so there's a way
you can trademark
uh a name locally like in a state right
and then there's a way that you can
trademark something federally and it's
basically protecting a brand or a name
or a concept or something like that so
I didn't have to do too much anything
and the truth be told we have a a friend
we all three of us have a friend named C
who trademarked it for me in my name and
gave it to me as a gift it was saying
listen and then since you resigned I
went ahead and trademarked that for you
so 101 won the beat or just one one to
beat yeah so the next time that that
name is heard in Arizona it'll be
because you owned it and he was like
listen if you want a radio station we
can talk about buying you a station you
know getting you some you know placement
or whatever so you know it's just it's
just being real friendly you know I mean
but I I do own the name so no one else
can use it in terms of the Federal Trade
is that why they they changed their name
um they changed the name because the
backlash from their black employee who's
the most tenured who had the most you
know clicks on the website you know what
I'm saying right had resigned in such
public fashion over allegations that
they weren't being fair to the community
they were just taking money and not
giving anything back and that was my
charge listen if you're not a black
person but you partake in Black Culture
the way I say it is we don't mind if you
eat from our table just make sure you
save us a seat I think that that's more
than fair right more than fair charge to
anybody who partakes in Black Culture
and uses it to make money just imagine
that these are human beings who actually
have to live and die in order to feed
these stories to exist and we don't want
to live this we weren't just born to die
and sell dope and you know struggle
that's right that's not fair and if you
are profiting off of that pain you know
I'm saying if we ask for a seat at the
table we only ask for 30 minutes
initially right in the middle of 30
minutes and it didn't even have to be 30
minutes a week yeah 30 minutes a week
and it didn't even have to be us on the
station yeah it could have been anybody
else we would have just made sure that
we got the guest book you know what I'm
saying so
that's been my charge but you know after
that backlash the station rebranded yeah
they had to make some changes
um are they aware every time you Google
1011 the beat the stories came up first
are they aware that you own that now uh
they will be after they hear this I
didn't have no reason to stunt on nobody
you know what I'm saying like I'm trying
to do good good work and and I believe
now those people they learned a lesson I
never I worked with them for a long time
they weren't bad people they just made a
bad call again but you know they've
since done a couple of things the shows
they're committed to to making things
right so I don't want to like keep
beating up on them but I gotta tell the
story how it went so if I say your name
in the interview it's because that's how
it happened
so yeah man but you know for now I'm
focused on making sure that we have
conversations
um that are dedicated to Healing you
know conversations dedicated to you know
giving insight into what it what
different people's experiences might be
like
um trying to create more empathetic
allies we we feel like we'll find allies
for the plight of black and brown people
right in the spaces where we broadcast
and you know podcast as well
um and we we need to give them insights
so that when they go home for
Thanksgiving and they sit in their
uncle's presence or their their dad's
presence they know how to have
conversations that will show that okay
there's a different way of looking at
this pops you know I'm saying these
people actually have some other you know
what I'm saying and so we we lean on a
lot of great thinkers I I never thought
I was a DJ I never thought I'd be in
this position you know we both were you
know he was DJing for the Phoenix Suns
you know what I'm saying so who who's to
say you know what tomorrow holds but
when the Call Comes and you're the only
person holding the ball what do you do
you run with the ball so
you know that's how we ended up you know
here and and
to to piggyback off of that we've done
our best to grow it even more right so
again I mentioned the bi in Daily
podcast making sure we have platforms to
tell these stories but Q uh hopefully
I'm not putting your business out there
but he recently acquired hip-hop weekly
the the media imprint yeah so that's
that's his now and you know he can you
know tell stories how they deserve to be
told
um I know you're shaping it up don't let
me speak for you no I mean we we plan to
relaunch top of the year
um and a bunch of people that we know
and a bunch of people we don't know
Freelancers journalists photographers
and up and coming artists will have a
space that kind of always existed but
didn't have the light that it deserved
right so just kind of rebranding that
magazine because hip-hop weekly is like
kind of like a you know it's it's uh
would you say it's kind of like the
tabloid version of like it's kind of
like Hollywood unlocked but in a
magazine form yeah kind of before all
these before all that was existed yeah
for sure so and it was still in print I
could be next to Like Us Weekly yeah you
know all that so coming back to the
digital space with something that was a
printed magazine right and and really
creating a a new platform for not just
creators but artists that were not when
they're artists are creators but not
just the people who capture the stories
but the people that create them right so
um you know rebranding relaunching you
know doing covers again like really
giving people something to to read and
yeah because the coverage prior I think
was very like uh it was like a bunch of
stuff going on on the cover I mean you
said it it was just like how if you go
see an US Weekly Magazine in the grocery
store now like a bunch of headlines yeah
we're trying to do more classic covers I
was gonna say the headline real model is
like a little race it's a little harder
to for the Internet it's like yeah it's
like harder to keep up if you're
printing Because by the time it gets
printed who knows how the story's
changed Bob yeah
especially with the Carnation like every
other day we record our show a day ahead
of time and it's like Jesus I can't even
[ __ ] we can't even keep up with all
the wild [ __ ] happens speaking of that
you own white lives of matter
indeed yeah so uh so for people who
don't know so this is the other part I
was going to tell you you
technically own the term White lives
matter right the trademark that's a
federal trademark that applies to the
whole United States of America so yeah
if you were to go in and look it up it's
owned by Civic Cipher LLC we acquired
the trademark from an individual in uh
our orbit
um who procured that and then also filed
for all lives matter uh federally
because they weren't trademarked right
funnily enough and so this person did
that and wanted to ensure that the right
people would benefit from those you know
sayings and we ultimately ended up
acquiring it through our lawyer Morris
um so now we are the deciders of who
profits from those terms uh White lives
matter and all lives matter so if you
ever see any individual selling that
shirt it's either illegal or they have
had to come down our street and knock on
our door and we had to negotiate the
terms of that cell so when are you suing
Kanye West uh well if Kanye West or any
other person decides to sell because he
hasn't sold anything has he hasn't sold
those yet right sure decides to sell
something
um you know he would either have to get
clearance or he has to face our
trademark attorneys because I saw he was
just giving away the shirts and uh Skid
Row he was just passing him out the
homeless do that and then that's that's
totally fine but in terms of profiting
off of a statement that
is intended to dilute the
um significance and the thrust of a
statement as affirming as black lives
matter
um the right people should decide who
who gets money off of that who gets
money off of that exactly if you wanted
to affirm for yourself that white lives
matter in your own path through life
that is your right you can make you can
paint it on your shirt no one can stop
you but if you as soon as you want to
sell it
um you are infringing on Civic Cipher
llc's federally protected trademark and
you will be sued wow yes any anyone you
can look it up any lawsuits yet no no we
just sent out cease and desist to people
that were selling bootleg versions of
that stuff oh I didn't send them out the
lawyers did we know we're not lawyers
somebody said was selling fake White
lives matter shirts oh yeah yeah yeah
and people sell and and then the awesome
matter too once that comes back you know
the cnds go out and then you know if if
you ever do see a person selling them
again they came and they knocked on our
door
we choose to donate that to certain
organizations or whatever then that is
our right and we can decide how that
money gets spent and hopefully it'll be
for the betterment of the community's
most impacted by folks like most likely
to wear those those shirts so
um you know there's your Catch-22 we
learned from Byron Allen that you you
want to own the game not the game piece
and so uh and just again some some
fortunate sequence of events took place
and we ended up with
sort of the hot topic of the day this
white lives matter thing and you know
even you could look it up yourself
you'll see Civic Cypher Studios the
address everything is all there right
yeah what are your thoughts on just
everything Kanye from the last two weeks
or so it's been a rough two weeks I'll
let you jump on that it's been a lot
started it started with the wildlife
matter thing which was like okay
this guy's true I felt like he was just
trolling for the wrong reasons real
hurtful yeah but no cubes got some
interesting thoughts
drink Champs interview is wild
wild yeah
um
Kanye West is kind of the leader
of a really really interesting movement
right there's there's a time in the last
several years where
group think right right being contrarian
to group think
is being accepted as intelligence right
if I just think the opposite of what
everybody else is thinking then I'm
gonna just show everybody how
how on top of it I am right no research
no studying no information just whatever
everybody seems to be saying say the
opposite I'm gonna say the opposite and
I'm going to show you guys how free
thinking I am right which isn't
irresponsible if you just work down the
street at Panda Express and that's just
what you want to get off your chest but
when you have the stature and the
influence of someone like Mr West he's
probably the most influential human
being ever it's grossly irresponsible
yeah and if you've noticed he's
developed a bit of a zealot following
where in their minds he can't do or say
anything wrong even if it's blatantly
and flagrantly untrue We can't agree on
what's facts anymore I think people are
just more likely to forgive Kanye
because they love his music so much yeah
there's that and they love his shoes and
they but I feel like that only goes so
far and I think he might have hidden
that he might he's might have hit that
wall of like people he has some people
with him though Kev that want to also be
viewed as Leaders of in the in the free
thought space right and they think that
by again just bucking the trend of
whatever I'm contrarian about and my
circles and on Instagram and on Twitter
I can be viewed as free thinking and and
of a higher level of intelligence just
by saying the opposite of whatever is
popular accepted opinion even when
popular accepted opinion is based on
fact right I'm just going to say the
opposite so I can show you guys how woke
and and learn it I am and he's the
leader of that school yeah it really
really is as you can see
um I think it's kind of spinning out of
control yeah with trying to come across
as a leader it's
it's pretty wild cool because
technically he is a leader the problem
is is he doesn't carry himself like he
has those responsibilities yeah
and like uh you know I think that uh
some of the anti-semitic [ __ ] he's
saying is crazy it's so hurtful it's
just wild yeah and
so like he said he had said something
like Jewish people have controlled
black voices for so long
and if you if if you feel that way
can't you just say black people it's
time we start controlling our voices
without mentioning without mentioning
another absolutely especially when
you're the self-proclaimed richest black
man in the history of the United States
you sir can absolutely create that space
where we own our own stories our own
voice and our own platform right
like even with the Trump thing like
I understood what he was trying to do he
was trying to push the line that says
hey the Democratic party been taking
advantage of black voters this whole
entire time
let me show y'all you don't have to like
when he really explained it out I was
like well I get the what he's trying to
do but the way he did it you can do that
without him you could just say it buddy
or you could yeah you could say it
without looking like your [ __ ] your
hug like he looked like a a kid who met
his favorite celebrity I mean he called
the guy a father figure he was like his
dad like come on dude yeah and so I
think like Kanye is just very
um
he's just very the way he communicates
what he thinks to be right is just so
short-sighted and it's just very like
it's like dude like like the White lives
matter thing he's like I think he what
did he say he said
um
black lives matter was a scam there I
ended it and it's like you could be very
you know
um
critical of black lives matter the
organization yes as Kanye West yes and B
and point out a lot of [ __ ] but what is
the point of doing that while also
putting on a shirt that says white lives
about it I want to add to that though
because you know I I hear a lot of that
stuff you know but for someone in that
position you have to bear in mind that
well there's a bunch of different
there's a bunch of different black lives
matter organization let me let me say
this okay so I come from the tradition
of
uh so my teacher Dr Camille West yeah
you know her shout out Dr westenberg
Shout Out Dr westenberg
um made sure that I learned
what movements look like what struggles
look like you know what I mean so we
learned from the Panthers we learn from
you know uh all these these
organizations these individuals with
groups and and movements around them you
know the stokleys the Baldwins James
Baldwin all these folks right and these
folks that had contrarian opinions that
that ran against what was popular in the
country at the time
and you know people used every trick in
the book to uh frame folks as being this
that or the other right
um just because you know these are
information Wars right this is it's a
matter of influencing public opinion if
you can make Dr King look like the most
evil human being who ever lived most
when Dr King was like most people
opposed his views most now it's all good
because he's been rebranded right so I
take when people talk bad about BLM the
organization I take that with a grain of
salt I I also add to it that BLM has
done a lot since Trayvon Martin died in
2012 right it's been around since then
right and they've done a lot of good
things and every organization deserves
to be able to grow up you know the
Kennedys the Great American family they
got their money they got their start in
prohibition
in prohibition mean they were selling
illegal products in the United States of
America that's how they got their money
were able to attain political
um status in this country
um and and you know they they say most
most every uh Fortune is built on the
back of a crime or something like that
there's a popular saying
um which I don't believe necessarily
that BLM has done anything criminal
they've just done things that perhaps
most folks don't agree with in terms of
how things should be spent ins based on
what I've read they haven't like robbed
any banks or killed any people or
anything yeah I just think that there's
a lot of criticism a lot of the victims
that
um
have obviously been highly publicized
that has fueled their movements or have
not reaped the benefits sure and that's
uh where there's a lot of the higher ups
in Black lives matter who are
millionaires now that weren't
millionaires prior to you're saying the
same thing as me so in terms of your
opinion on how they spend money you know
it's not illegal like you said they're
not criminals right so who's to say but
you know I know this versus Kanye West
to be so critical of something without
giving a context without knowing himself
without having walked in those shoes
right I feel like that's kind of a a
tough I remember reading a story about
BLM
um and I don't want to act like the
great defender of BLM but I just don't
hear the other side of it in the media
and because I've seen this in history
right again I take it with a grain of
salt but the other side of this is
um one of the stories that I've seen was
BLM
bought a a house a mansion something
like this I was framed and then I had to
do some investigation because obviously
we do the show right after you have to
talk about it yeah right I did some
investigation and the way BLM was
looking at that purchase was like no
this was a facility we have to have a
place that's protected where they can't
put bugs on the wall and tap stuff we
can't be renting a place we can't you
know we have to have something with a
gate we have to with certain
requirements where we can House people
you know whatever and this place
afforded us all of these uh things that
we needed and so this was a reasonable
purchase for a business like out or for
a movement organization like ours right
and for anyone else that had an opinion
prior to reading that that article they
would look at it like okay of course
these black people got this money and
now they're spending it they're they're
throwing parties or whatever and that's
the way the article framed it but when
you dig it one layer deeper ask one
person a question you get a little bit
more context you're like okay that makes
sense that's entirely reasonable and
it's not this nefarious operation and so
again Kanye West or whoever else who has
been critical but you know this is the
person we're talking about right now him
saying these things again is very
hurtful because it's very easy to
support
someone black if you're the same Kanye
West who goes on the news and says
George Bush doesn't care about black
people these are my people out here when
my people go in the store they say that
they're looting but when it's white
people that go into the store this is
about Katrina him talking about when
when white people go in the store
they're getting supplies because they're
desperate when my people go in the store
Kanye West said that right and then he
said George Bush doesn't care about
black people I remember watching that
yeah I remember watching that so if
that's the same person who can give a
little bit of Grace and understanding
and context to a conversation for him to
then take it all away from BLM who's
been active on the street I haven't seen
Kanye West in any protest you know
clearly not the same person though but
yeah sure sure but you know I'm holding
them to that standard that he set for
himself right I've seen BLM since 2012
I've been at the library right with
these people in small little meetings
with Dr westenberg because I'm the
person on the radio in my city hey we
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our partners at Odd Socks
our presenting sponsor here at the
podcast listen Christmas Time's
approaching faster than you think I mean
we're like [ __ ] a month and a half
away or some [ __ ] whatever uh get some
Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flaming hots
for you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out
there my favorite just the odd Sox
Basics they're just so comfy literally
the most comfortable sock in the world
I'm holding the [ __ ] sock right now
you can save 20 off plus they got boxers
now baby all right go to odd
socksofficial.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at Odd Socks and the podcast at
the same [ __ ] time let's get back to
the interview and there's like there's
very like localized chapters yeah I'm
sure yeah so there's like a black lives
matter La there's a black lives matter
Phoenix Metro
so all of those are very like separate
from I think I think I think you can't
just paint the whole thing with one
brush right but I do think that in the
same way we were talking like Candace
Owens is capitalizing off of everything
she's looking at it through I think a
lot of people are doing it on the other
side too sure sure yeah I mean listen
it's not impossible that these things
because I know this I just talked to
Killer Mike so I call Killer Mike and
I'm like yo where do I donate my money
and if Killer Mike tells me don't donate
it there donated here I'm like cool
listen I just talked to Dr Camilla
westenberg and I tell you what if
somebody comes down my street and says
hey we would like to acquire the federal
trademark to create and produce and sell
white lives anything that says white
lives matter on it I know that the NAACP
is ready and willing to receive a check
from Civic Cipher LLC you know what I'm
saying and then I know some people like
you said there are local chapters the
people that I've seen do the work the
people that inspired Civic Cipher
there's a woman named Zara tacola you
know I love her to death She's My Shiro
you know what she's doing she has a
501c3 they do Grassroots uh work in in
Arizona and you know nationally she has
a national profile I would love to
donate money to her because I believe it
because you know her I was going to say
if people want to help out how do they
vet where they should put their money
well you can start by donating the Civic
Cipher you can hit civicsipher.com
because we are on it you know I risk my
whole career here to to bring some like
I was the man I was doing my thing you
know what I'm saying yeah I'm telling
you like I got to convince you but you
know we was there together right but um
yeah I'm I'm I we have a segment on our
show called uh Baba uh become a better
Ally right it comes from uh one of the
African languages means father as well
so sort of a reference to like guidance
or whatever right become a better Ally
um and that segment we often talk about
the NAACP right so it's the oldest most
uh established organization that that
moves in such a way to try to create
more opportunities and more political uh
strength for impoverished communities
black and brown you know I do believe we
do believe in unity between all
marginalized groups of people so you'll
see me you hear me say black and brown a
lot
um but I I also mean you know our aapi
brothers and sisters I mean our uh
Native brothers and sisters uh
indigenous brothers and sisters
um our lgbtqia plus brothers and sisters
anybody you nailed it if you were born
if you feel like you were born with a
strike against you and you want to join
a movement where love is at the center
of the conversation where we are trying
to to make sure everybody has a voice
and it's heard and it's protected
um and there's equality as as far as we
can take that then then that's the
movement that you want to be on and we
didn't ask to be in this position again
you know with all these stations
carrying our message around this whole
entire country but now that we're here
there's an even greater responsibility
to be true to it and you know if they
bury my my sons carry me on my last day
and they bury me in the ground and the
last thing I did was record an episode
of Civic Cipher I'd still say this was a
life well lived has there been anything
um
because I know you guys were doing uh
some conversations about like the
vaccine and and obviously there's a lot
of hesitancy within the you know black
and brown Community to get the vaccine
sure
um it turns out a lot of the hesitancy
was maybe well warranted
maybe uh I I I I I I
never found that to be true in the uh
this the studies that I've done well I
was going to ask like if you guys do an
episode on something and then kind of
like the facts evolve
um oh yeah we we have you guys
it's beyond revisiting because that's
important we were wrong
I think that's important too because a
lot of people wouldn't do that yeah I
want to say before we move on
that with with lives matter right before
we move on from that
black lives matter
is a statement that is true that is true
correct and a lot of the reason why you
know Ramses and I go back and forth I
don't do a lot of the apologizing or
explaining on behalf of the organization
because Kevin Quinton and Ramses right
can be scrutinized our LLCs can be
scrutinized our companies can be
scrutinized and be wrong and make
mistakes right black lives matter period
as a statement is true is true yeah
so I don't even have to talk about dot
org right right right right and all of
the other lives matter statements
came just to oppose the statement right
black lives matter yeah I was just
talking to Akon about it and that's what
I was saying I was like you know the
origin of this was because obviously
black lives don't matter as much as
everyone else is correct so it's like
black lives matter as a statement is 100
true and Kanye's got to be smart enough
to realize the connotations
like white lives matter no one was
saying that in but now they're saying it
to combat
an obvious the same with black eye on
the country the same with all lives
matter it was those statements were born
just to oppose the statement black lives
matter not to oppose the organization or
anything wrong that they did right so
that's why it hits the way that it does
because we know where those statements
were born from why they were even
created why people say them they State
they say them to stand in opposition to
the statement that black people's lives
are are important and that they're
worthy of existing yeah they were worthy
of equality you know during breast
cancer awareness month we don't argue
all cancer multiple sclerosis is also
worth talking about we don't do that
when it saved the whales we don't talk
about well the birds aren't migrating
like we don't do that right with
anything else and I know you're right
you know what I mean so the reason why I
get so disappointed and passionate and
angry about it is because of what you
said he's smart enough to know that yeah
and still rides this horse of really not
just division
but intentional attention mongering for
statements that are
flagrantly opposed to something so
simple in its nature right right if
you're such a free thinker
how come if we check the boxes on the
points that you make they line up
so accurately and in such perfect
alignment with white supremacist agendas
with aligning yourself with people like
homegirl who for the dollar get on the
mic and say anything right with dude in
a red hat like you can make your free
thinking statements without having to
then attach yourself to things that are
so opposed to our children being able to
go to school and be okay happy birthday
Millennium you know what I'm saying
that's why I get so passionate and upset
about it my kids are black and Mexican
right and you were in the mega hat for
the dude whose whole campaign was build
the wall to keep Mexican people out like
dog water really right fam
so George Bush hates black people or
doesn't care about black people and that
was your stance but now White lives
matter and you know you're trolling and
then on the very very wild drinks you
know uh yeah
he tripled down on his anti-semitic
rhetoric like really bro
yes it's rough especially to me to me
the craziest Kanye [ __ ] was the George
Floyd [ __ ] oh bro for and for what yeah
and then your your Source material on
that it's a Candace is a Candace Owens
documentary the lady who's been so she's
gone out of her way since the man died
to tell us how awful he was as if that
makes the fact that the man killed him
okay right like it doesn't matter
all of like they say all lives matter
yeah well so does the guy who had a drug
problems life matter who has a bad
criminal that's all I'm saying all lives
matter until do they all lives are
immigrants or prisoners or convicts
criminals I'm glad you said that because
you know people we feel like especially
on the show we feel like people deserve
a little dignity we don't feel like
anybody is simply the worst thing
they've ever done
um people deserve to be forgiven we
we're not the biggest fans of cancel
culture you know what I mean because
there's people who make mistakes making
honest mistakes right and you know if we
condemn everyone who makes a mistake to
you know the the margins of society then
they're just going to find Community
within each other and then we bolster
the opposition hey guys we got to stop
the interview to tell you about our good
folks over at bluechoo.com that's right
listen you got to go to Bluetooth right
now sign up for uh Bluetooth with the
promo code bootleg you're gonna get your
first month for free Bluetooth the same
active ingredient adds Viagra Ana Cialis
but in a chewable form that's right you
pop the blue shoe chew that thing wash
it down with your beverage of choice and
then get to work with that hard [ __ ]
[ __ ] of yours your dick is going to be
harder than trigonometry was in high
school ladies and gentlemen it's gonna
be [ __ ] raw like you know uh Ryu and
Street Fighter he'd be like and then he
does the [ __ ] this is gonna be
your dick it's gonna be like where I use
[ __ ] uppercut you know what I'm
saying God bless whoever's on the
receiving end of that consensually of
course they're going to thank you for
taking the blue shoe so go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
all right I'm talking free month right
to your doorstep Indiscreet packaging no
awkward doctor's visits all right it's
all online you don't have to worry about
going and sitting in a waiting room and
be like hey Doc uh my dick I could use a
little a pep in my step and then it's
awkward you gotta look at this old [ __ ]
talking about your dick he might ask you
to pull it out who [ __ ] knows what's
going on at Bluetooth none of that's
happening bluetooth.com and they also
got the new brand new
a mint flavored chewable which has
vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know what I mean get
the mint chewable yeah your wife will
thank you your girlfriend no thank you
your boyfriend will thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll
thank you as long as it's legal all
right let's get back to the interview go
to bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
that's it there's some stuff that you
know you have to learn and you know when
we're talking about
uh Candace Owens and and Kanye West and
those people that those things break
down their entire argument you know I
mean it's like they there's no Grace
there's no nothing if you are black if
you were Brown if you had a problem if
you made a mistake whatever it's held
over your head
um and as though it's now Justified for
you to be dead you know and that's not
the way the legal system in this country
works that's not the way it's not how a
supposed thing should work right you
know you deserve to have a full life
make your mistakes and learn from them I
think obviously just taking candy zones
and Kanye West out of the conversation I
think that the extreme of each side yeah
does extremely wild [ __ ] yes sure sure
I'll give you that that is very um
that just kind of like turn like every
each side turns each other off in a way
that there it removes any new Nuance to
any Middle Ground anymore well it's it's
it's two different realities and it's
also like on each side like common sense
is just gone
I'll give you that too so it's like now
it's like okay where are the
conversations happening
for people to kind of meet in the middle
on some of these issues and I'm not
saying like issues in terms of like uh
obviously police brutality everybody
should agree that's [ __ ] up but
there's a lot of [ __ ] that like I would
say most people if you were to take the
craziest like wild [ __ ] Trump
supporter and you would take like
you know the wildest no not not you not
you I mean like you know there's some
much further extremes than us the wild
yeah we're much closer to the middle
than you realize yeah like the extreme
left [ __ ] is pretty wild and it gives
like the entire left like such a bad is
and the same way that you know uh the
crazy right-wing people it it just makes
uh nuance and conversation almost
obsolete and in the in terms of like not
being able to
uh I feel like the tribal aspect of it
is so bad to where it's like okay well
we think this over here so if we take
this over here
like the vaccine scene to me was like
one of those things that was so crazy
because I saw people getting demonized
for not wanting to do something to their
own body and I'm like
this is crazy this is not a right wing
or left-wing thing this is a personal
decision so I'm vaccinated but what what
you said that's important you asked us
about having to correct like we have to
apologize with haste right if we say
something that it's the next show oh
yeah has to be the first 30 minutes got
to be about that right we have we it's
required or our show is [ __ ] right right
like what are you guys talking about
this last week and it was trash you know
I never addressed it again like yeah
right yeah but what you just said is the
bar of this whole thing the Nuance
doesn't exist anymore it's all extreme
this or not when I was a kid and Reagan
was the president my mom did not agree
with his politics but her friends at
work that did they weren't beefing
because right there's points and
platforms that political people campaign
on and for most of those they're extreme
because that's how they get their
baseball
but in the middle they there used to be
[ __ ] that everybody agreed was good yes
that does not exist anymore so you bring
up the vaccine
we're interviewing
um an epidemiologist right she can tell
you without any hesitation straight to
your face that we all should have got
vaccinated right that does not mean that
100 of people that get vaccinated will
live long healthy lives right but that's
how it will be dissected right a hundred
people got vaccinated 70 of them got
sick passed away whatever right and now
that's the vaccine's fault and that's
just not how any vaccine has ever I
think the problem
the problem with the vaccine was that it
was introduced as like an end-all be-all
like would you get this you're good and
then they kept introducing more shots
and then on top of that they were
withholding the fact that if you already
had covid that it was actually better
than getting the vaccine
let me let me make sure that I paint
this picture with you Kevin yeah the
political landscape of the country at
that time was that every single thing
that made headlines had to be
politicized and sold and it still is
that so that's the problem
to me like I would I'm I got vaccinated
but I was like I'm not getting boosted
like at all I'm straight not getting
boosted I've had covet [ __ ] twice I'm
vaccinated I'm good
but my kid who's 16 is like dad's a
Trumper he's an anti-vaxxer also and I'm
like what do you mean I'm a healthy 30.
you're all so reasonable yeah right most
people aren't reasonable uh
and I don't know when that part happened
that's my I think it happened in Houston
I think Trump is who really turned up
each side now you see why I don't rock
with buddy yeah
[Music]
Trump definitely did that and I think
that like he made it to where he made
everything tribal yeah and it was
already tribal it was already tribal but
he made it crazy yeah it was different
yeah and I I just think that like uh
yeah I don't know man I just man we're
in a place where politically like each
side is batshit crazy at times
you know I can I can say Joe Biden's
done some good [ __ ] I'll say he's done
some bad [ __ ] but you should be able to
say that you should be critical of
anybody who's in charge especially that
scene you should be hyper critical right
like I voted for Joe Biden I also think
he's like not a great president now is
he a better president than Trump would
have been on on most things yes on the
things that are most important to me yes
I want to say this too because you said
something I don't want the narrative to
get out there the wrong way okay
we watched you and me we watched the
presidential election in 2016. Bernie
Sanders yeah yes and I want to make sure
that you said that because you said
Aiden your son thought that you might be
a trump or something like that Kevin is
not a Trumper no no no no no no no I
mean I voted for Joe Biden at the same
and I hate Joe Biden nobody listening
might think like that Joe Biden was the
worst candidate that the Democrats ran
and I still voted for it I know I know
but I want to make sure people out there
listening know that you never voted for
Trump at all
no of course yeah no but I just think
that like for example like if Trump does
something good when he was president if
he did something good be like oh yeah he
did I agree with this that doesn't mean
you agree with him or you're a
Republican or you love him yes right and
then it's that part right it's people
subscribed to him
the person right it's it's the culture
he's a cult leader you couldn't even
it's like the con it's like the Kanye
[ __ ] but just you know for white people
I had people like dming me in
defensively
I'm like yo I'm like yo I know you and
your kids like you're you're upset with
me because I said something about this
man that's true that you've never met
that doesn't care about you that you
don't know like people really really
subscribe to him on like a zealot I
think that the Trump thing got so out of
hand
that it got everyone else so much out of
character that now if you're on
the conservative side of the aisle now
you can point at the other aisle and be
like well you guys did this you guys
purposely like the hunter Biden [ __ ] is
kind of like a black eye on media
because they purposely withheld a real
story
collectively Twitter Facebook New York
Times came out
and like their left shouldn't be doing
that right we would no one should be
doing nobody but what I'm saying is like
Trump was so crazy that it really felt
like
if he gets reelected we don't know
what's going to happen it can get bad we
would have bust at the seams that it
made
everyone else stooped to his level yeah
and now everyone's hands are dirty Yeah
country to the right once he showed that
there was no line he wouldn't cross
that's what I'm saying so it's like now
it's like okay
I mean I hope that um obviously
you know there's somebody who runs
besides Joe Biden that's you know
younger and more able what up y'all we
gotta stop the interview real quick tell
you about our good friends at my bookie
that's right man my bookie is where you
want to get this money and uh enjoy uh
being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview what you
think about Gavin Newsom
I think I lived here and it was terrible
so I don't know man I don't think I'm
not sure Gavin Newsom will be the guy
you think he better than what we got
yeah yeah yeah for sure but Gavin Newsom
also like destroyed like most small
businesses in California like all the
restaurants I was going to so they're
all closed and it was all kind of
and you look like Florida's death rates
were not any I think if it's Newsome
versus DeSantis Newsome's gonna have a
hard time in that debate
um well listen I would like it to be one
of the things that I will say I would
rather it be them two than Trump and who
yes yes as long as Trump is not in the
cards literally anything else
more damaging I just think it sucks
because like you would think Kamala
Harris would have taken the opportunity
to like be the next person sure but like
she's not gonna win she's kind of faded
to the background and the truth is like
I said these media Wars now that we're
playing this media game we understand
exactly how media works and how it
shapes Optics around people
um you know I went from
loving Kamala to despising her to loving
her and cheering for her to despising
her and I realized looking back on all
that I'm like okay so when she got
elected this was great and then she was
like imprisoning black people at this
point she's doing that before she got
elected but you know I'm trying to say
I'm trying to tell the story about how
no no no there's a like I mean that she
becomes the VP and then it's like Oh
Black that's why it's important to have
nuanced conversations sure sure and then
this is why there's a show called
breaking points on YouTube it's like a
kind of like an old school conservative
young dude in a old school like liberal
lady yeah you told me about the show and
the show's like they just do the news
and then at the end they each give their
take so like if you want to watch like
the their opinion on something they'll
find one thing to kind of like but it's
like like you said the media is
weaponized in such a crazy way now do
they find the middle ground
yeah or they just agree to disagree yeah
but which is okay you were saying
something though um uh the way that the
media space is right now in our with
with the opportunity that we have with
Civic Cipher in the conversations that
we can have we understand that we both
kind of share similar views but we also
recognize that there are other people we
call them our brothers and sisters and
we mean that who may not agree with us
but we have to get a message to them in
a in a meaningful way that they will
receive them and War fire and brimstone
is not going to do that that's why like
you know it's a topic that I think like
people
on and I'm obviously pro-choice
um
but how dare you no but this is the
thing right is like if someone's a joke
if someone is in pro-choice that means
that they literally think that abortion
is murder
so if they literally think that
then you have to respect that they don't
want it to happen that's that's what the
problem is is if someone says that they
are against abortion then they all of a
sudden they hate women
you know what I'm saying so but the
problem is what you said though most of
the people that come out on the other
side of it because if I'm gonna approach
you let's talk about the vaccine right
if I'm going to approach you
as anti-vaccine or Pro if I cannot have
an intelligent simple conversation with
you on either side of it then what am I
doing and my thing is I don't even think
it's worth having the conversation with
people who are anti-abortion because
they literally think it's murder yeah so
if you think something is murder then I
get it you have to put there's a system
on that all the way through though so I
was describing sort of the the
temperament of our show and I think that
this point so I appreciate I think this
point helps us illustrate it
um
if someone has like for instance you
mentioned the vaccine
um if someone has an opinion on what
they're going to do with their body that
sort of thing we we have to respect that
and I get it we of course on the show we
recommended that you know communities
hardest hit by Kobe right take the
vaccine we had taken the vaccine we we
both had covet you know we understood
sort of what we're up against and we
didn't our due diligence in terms of the
research right at the time
um
so making those recommendations or
having those conversations were not
necessarily rooted in someone else's
oppression right
um we have conversations on our show you
know what I mean you can have your
difference of political beliefs right
and I won't I'll I'll allow you those
beliefs provided they are not rooted in
my oppression right so when it comes to
the abortion issue um which is a woman's
issue so none of us in theory should be
great Champions or great voices in in
that space But in terms of we all have
women that we love in our lives and you
know we have platforms and so we have to
kind of
you walk that line as best we can
recognizing that other people have their
opinions on what needs to happen if a
woman is pregnant and does not want to
have the baby
those opinions
in theory they should only exist
provided they're not rooted in the
oppression of some other group of people
and if you can make the case that I'm
pro-abortion or I'm or I'm I'm sorry
pro-life pro-life pro-life exactly
and women look at that like well that
decision is rooted in my oppression that
that decision oppresses me it limits
what it is that I can do with my own
body I'm a free freestanding human being
endowed with Consciousness to those
people though it doesn't matter it's not
just her body whatever whatever but the
thing is when we have these
conversations I guess what I'm saying is
like what we were talking about earlier
right if like if someone tells me that
they're Pro pro-life like I'm not gonna
just assume that they're a terrible
person no no but the problem is is like
if like if if somebody came out and said
I'm Pro or I'm pro-life right they
automatically get this whole entire
right and then that's what I'm saying we
don't have to write people off that's
politics too though for sure well let me
let me finish we don't have to write
people off for feeling how they feel but
we cannot give equal footing if someone
else's opinion is rooted in the
oppression of someone else by the nature
of our show because that has been used
to oppress black people since black
people arrived on these Shores that
formula that format and so we by by the
by the virtue of the show that we do the
nature of the show we cannot we cannot
do that so if someone else has a
separate opinion we have to still call
them our brothers and our sisters who
have a different opinion right we we do
our best to illustrate their points on
our show and oftentimes those points
have value they're credible points they
do not reflect the reality that I mean
listen my thing is if someone's
religious right yeah really this is a
great one religious is like yo
I think that the baby's being murdered
so you want me to co-sign that I
personally am an atheist so I don't give
a [ __ ] about none of that [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying I don't care it just
like smoke them as long as no as long as
it's uh a certain obviously within a
certain range I think the late term of
British just crazy
um but uh I just think that like it's
like it's it's kind of like back to what
I'm saying about the vaccine thing where
it's like yo like there's nurses who are
heroes during the pandemic who got fired
because they wouldn't get vaccinated and
guess what they were right
see you talking about something I don't
know about so there's actual nurses sure
people who work in hospitals
I just have not come across that story
myself or those yes there's people who
lost their job listen I know that again
there's this is and this is the point
we're making there's credible
conversations there's credible ideas and
beliefs on both sides uh on the black
Information Network daily podcast it's a
show that I do every day I have a uh
maybe twice a week feature that I do
it's called one more thing so check that
out at binnews.com or iheart.com you'll
see me
um I'm the one with the afro next to
Katie Couric anyway
um
on uh that platform when I do that show
I say something that I believe really
works in this space and this is sort of
the temperament we have on Civic Cypher
as well I say listen I don't profess to
be right
um I would love to hear you our
listeners thoughts on this and maybe
somewhere in the middle we'll find our
way together forward right right or wait
our way forward together right and so
this is kind of the formula that we have
to have bear in mind on Civic Cipher we
have to take a show that is talking to
music programmers right and ask them to
turn the music off for an hour a week or
sometimes they bury in the middle of the
night that's fine we'll take it but we
have to convince these people to let us
have conversations in spaces where they
don't exist right and in doing that
we have to bear in mind that these
people's opinions these oftentimes
wealthy white men their opinions
politically May differ from ours and yet
and still they may listen to this show
and we need them to recognize that their
opinion is at least being represented it
will be challenged but it will be
represented and we will do our best to
represent their opinion fairly and we
will not be unfair the interesting thing
discourse you know obviously having some
sort of conversation is just I feel like
it's important we do that as often can
we get guests the troubling thing and I
hate to keep saying the word nuanced but
Kevin said it and it's important right
if I'm a fireman right and I no longer
believe in the science that water puts
fire out I can't be a fireman anymore
I'm on the clergy and I go to Seminary
and some scientists convinces me that
parts of the Bible are untrue that I
can't sit on the clergy anymore right
right if you are a medical professional
right doctor nurse
and you don't believe in the science of
medicine then you probably shouldn't be
a nurse anymore right your job in that
space yeah but the science of Medicine
the science of That vaccine has been
changed so much on the CDC CDC websites
and there's like monoclonal antibodies
and there's a lot of [ __ ] that they
purposely withheld in some of these
states that science-wise if I'm a nurse
and I'm like yo well the science says if
you have had covid then you're more safe
than if you get the vaccine then you can
practice so my thing is that there's
medicine right but my thing is is like
with the with the vaccine thing just you
could just go through and look at the
way CDC changed their [ __ ] from like
week to week so the science changed over
and over and over you can provide data
on both sides of that point no 100 and
that's why it's vaccinated and boosted
and whatever there might have been some
very harmful effects to that with Kevin
that were not right Quentin no and I
think that that's why it's like okay
like this isn't a one-size-fits-all
thing with the vaccine it wasn't a one
size fits-all thing and that's how it
was sold to the yeah to people well
listen on our show we said listen and if
you are a healthy person you know
whatever you can make these decisions if
you are a person yeah if you're elderly
if you're old no for sure then then you
don't yeah if you have our
recommendation what should have been
provided though like in all things is
the choice to do whichever one you that
you want it and
there's the the difference in saying if
you
are a person that's at risk you should
get the vaccine versus saying no one
should because there might be I also
think the person that's the difference
of saying if you're a person at risk you
should get it as opposed to saying you
have to get it correct that's what I
said when you tell people they have to
do something there should be a choice
they're going to be like wait what no we
we had to do that listen
now at this point it's it's different
from cutting a break you know 30 second
break talking up a ramp into you know
some new you know little baby record or
something like that where you're not
talking about the stakes aren't that
high right when you're having
conversations that are life and death
about police killing people for sure
political the political you can't just
have those in 30 seconds you have to you
have to and then you have to bear in
mind that other people have a different
vantage point this is something that I
learned but had to learn even deeper
levels doing this show right and we feel
like we are setting up a formula and a
template one that will carry into
hip-hop Weekly Magazine one that will
carry into other spaces on the black
Information Network daily podcast I told
you exactly the temperament that I have
where listen somewhere in the middle
we'll find our way forward okay of
course you don't have to be me I'm not a
trump person I'm not a kind you don't
have to do it like me but listen listen
what I'm saying and cooler heads will
prevent will prevail there's there's a
reasonable
um there's logic and reason on this side
of the argument and even if you don't
come all the way over you'll at least
see if you allow me the same if you
listen without open ears yeah and
recognize that I am a human being
endowed with Consciousness from our
common Creator I am just like you I want
my sons to to right watch me grow old
and then bury me at the end of mine yeah
of course right if you want that and I
want that then we have more in common
than we have in 100 difference and so
you can listen to my vantage point my
perspective my reality I can share it
with you and then in the middle because
I have no problem compromising you this
is something black people are very good
at right especially in this country's
history listen we don't need everything
we don't need it we don't need much soon
we just need to keep moving in the right
direction it just has to let our
brothers and sisters who are in power
controlling a lot more than we are at
the time catch up with where we're going
you know what I mean but we have found
our way through a lot of the muck that
this country was born out of right and
Civic Cipher I believe continues in that
tradition
um with the help of you know I our
listeners with the help of you know the
people that support us along the way
Kevin you you included um you know uh Dr
westenberg consults with us
um shout out Chris Thompson from the
black Information Network shout out Tony
coach from black Information Network
shout out you know all the programs
around the country that carry our show
and the programs that are flirting with
carrying our show as well you know we
are going to do our best to continue to
do right by everyone and as soon as we
learn something new that conflicts with
something old we will address it if we
learn something new that informs our
path forward right we will do our best
to guide the folks that listen to us
that way but you need to believe in the
heart and the temperament and the tone
of the show in order to ride this wave
with us but we feel like we are
committing Our Lives to a cause that
will make uh significant changes for all
of us not just black and brown people
but all of us because we do feel that
our brothers and sisters from the
Caucasian tribe
um deserve to learn how to be the best
version of themselves right as they
possibly can be they deserve that and if
we can show them what that looks like
for from our perspective then we feel
like they welcome that too this is why
we're on the air in Massachusetts and in
and in you know uh shoot Vermont right
places that you know I'm saying look
where there's not you know Mississippi
yeah that makes sense you know uh
Louisiana you know New Orleans Detroit
Atlanta you know those make sense but
you know places where people are really
like hey we'd love to carry the show
it's because of those type of people as
well so shout out to them if you are
listening to my voice you are my sister
if you're listening to my voice or my
brother we are we are trying to do
something here support us
civicscipher.com binnews.com
hiphopweekly.com
um well what's the Instagrams for
everybody hip-hop weekly uh Civic Cipher
and I am q Ward
yeah there it is I don't even think I
said my name so you're allowed uh you
got you guys put everything on YouTube
too right uh yeah yeah we're we're
revamping the YouTube right now but by
the time you hear this we'll have a
whole new approach to our YouTube
because we really want to make sure that
we're hitting people the way that that
we need to on that platform we we
created a radio show and it's grown
Beyond everything else borders yeah and
if you're out there selling White lives
matter shirts you're about to get sued
be clear by Morris go ahead just Sue
Kanye just do it
if we see someone profiting you know I
got a feeling he's gonna try to sell
those shirts well he's got to talk to us
first otherwise I don't think anybody
wants yeah first we listen we don't want
to hurt him jump off the porch listen we
don't want to come see us afterwards
honestly well there it is yeah it is so
specific Cipher appreciate y'all pulling
up we appreciate you welcome boom